I've come to the Hamish compound which
is one of the largest compounds military
compounds after babbles easier probably
the biggest it was thought to be
virtually impregnable it was taken it
has been cleared out and I've been
through it while we were there we were
brought by some of the rebel forces and
then by local civilians to this compound
here where it is a scene of mass murder
there's no other way of putting about it
putting it you look behind me you can
see what is basically a burnt-out
warehouse and we're not able to go we're
able to go inside I'm not going to go
inside yet to show everyone but that is
full of executed people that we estimate
53 bodies we've counted them so far the
estimate originally was 40 we have
eyewitnesses who were here we were
talking to them later they escaped and
we they say 150 people were murdered
here on the twenty-third and the 24th of
this month they say there are bodies of
two soldiers who have been hands tied
behind their backs the locals believe
that they refused to fire on the people
who were being held inside and that they
were then murdered apart from that
warehouse it's their body two bodies we
believe behind the camera and further
over here you can probably we can
actually look over there where people
are standing now they're talking to one
of the witnesses whose come back that is
somebody who survived the assault he
appears to have been shot played dead
and somehow got out where we'll come
back to that in a bit beneath where
they're standing there believed to be
more bodies buried so Liam is here he
was one of the local people who knew
about this from the very start he heard
this cylinder all happened on the
twenty-third of August is that right yes
on twenty-third of Fergus about
seven-thirty a local time in the evening
lot of time in Tripoli we are actually
I'm living about 200 meters from here
and I heard some people shouting from
this place really this place before is
not a military place it's an extra yeah
it's a next door behind this place this
place is before for its for agriculture
that's that's weird house you know for
agriculture you can say right soldier
and when we hear the the people shouting
we were about four or five people when
we come closer we heard some hand
pumpers and we and some guns are going
on and people are and then we try to
come closer but we we sell some snipers
about this building there they were
there are this building there and there
were some snipers who are shooting so we
went back right so after that few
minutes 10 15 minutes three people were
coming to our place there and they're
now in the hospital they were injured
and they are actually worth soldier they
were captured here in this place right
so we asked them what happened they told
us there were about 150 people we're
here actually there most of them are
civilians right said they were here made
some of them since one month more than
one or two months and we don't know we
asked the most of the number they told
us about 155 so what happened they told
they come they butcher this hand these
had Palmer's and then they start killing
them so we guess that about 7-10 people
were escaped and the rest of the people
now were killed actually it's a true
massacre right next day morning we tried
to come to this place so we find people
of military and told us please go away
right so we saved those three people in
the hospital and if you want to talk to
them you find them in the hospital and
then we wait till last night people this
area were cleared from the military and
then this morning we come here and we
found what you find actually and these
were civilians and yes civilians and
what is the feeling that these people
were killed always by Gaddafi forces or
by rebel forces because there is concern
that some if they were mercenaries the
rebels might have killed them what do
you think no no there they killed by
Gaddafi forces that's for sure then
that's according to the witnesses if you
can talk to them and according to the
people who actually escape from here
that's for sure and there comes back to
that horses okay well is that sure thank
you very thank you thank you okay
Anna EV there's an awful lot of work to
be done here as you can imagine instead
try and find out what happened but it's
one of the first instances that i can
remember whether the surviving witnesses
there's local witnesses and the evidence
is here so i think there's a lot to be
done to try and get to the bottom what
happened it just as a slight addendum to
the what is quite cool and pretty
gruesome finding it's a remarkable
movement of the rebel troops of the
southeast they are almost done the job
I've said it was impossible only last
night when i was talking to you but it
overnight they have come far far out of
town and they're now moving further out
to where they say there's one final
compound